BE BACK- WITH ALL OF YOU HERE.
APPROPRIATELY DISTANCED UP
BEFORE WE START AND I SEE THAT
THE COUPLE OF OUR OUR AUTHORS
ARE ALREADY HERE BUT BEFORE I
START WITH THAT THE AUTHORS
WANTED TO MAKE A COUPLE OF THE
OPENING STATEMENTS. FOR
PROTOCOLS SO FIRST OF ALL GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
FIRST ASSEMBLY AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE COMMITTEE DURING THE
COVE IT- NINETEEN STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING MATTERS TO ATTEND
TO BEFORE WE BEGIN. PLEASE BE
MINDFUL OF OUR DISTANCING EN
MASSE REQUIREMENTS WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AT H. T. T. P. S. A. L. T. C.
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G. O.
V. BACKSLASH. PLEASE NOTE THAT
ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED
TO THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT A MAY BE READ
INTO THE RECORD OR REPRINTED
DUE TO ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
GUIDANCE AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING SEATING FOR THIS
HEARING WILL BE VERY LIMITED
FOR PRESS AND FOR THE PUBLIC.
ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE
HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON
THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE ACT H.
T. T. P. S. COLON. FORWARD
SLASH FORWARD SLASH W. W. W.
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOC OF
FORWARD SLASH TODAY'S EVENTS
ARE PUBLIC CALL IN NUMBER FOR
WITNESSES IS. 916-692-8957 AND
THE PIN NUMBER IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN OF
REPEAT THAT NUMBER AGAIN OUR
PUBLIC CALL IN NUMBER FOR
WITNESSES IS NINE ONE SIX SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE. FIVE SEVEN
AND THE PIN NUMBER IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
AUTHORS THERE'S A LIMIT OF TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND TO.
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL A FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS IS TO APPROVE
THE COMMITTEE RULES. THEIR
MOTION SECOND. GREAT. CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE CALL
WILL CALL. PRESIDENT VOEPEL.
YOUR. FOR BERMAN HELLO SEVEN
BLACKIE RARE. YEAH. THANK YOU
FOR THE RULE BY OF THE FFS.
FIVE EIGHT MR VOEPEL. MOST IN
THE WORLD MEDARIA. I HEALTH. HI
WHEN I WALKED OUT FIVE HUNDRED
PORTABLE FIVE BEDROOM I LAST
WEEK. READ ONE FOR THE OTHER ON
THE- SO WE HAVE A NEW ON THE
WILL MISTER. AND SINCE MR SALEH
IS HERE PLEASE SEPARATE YOUR
BILL THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THAT WAS GERMAN MEMBERS LED
PRESENTS OPEN THREE WHICH WOULD
STAFF REALLY. OVER AT ALL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION. TO OVERSEE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WILL
ADULTS. THAT WOULD. FEDERAL
HEALTH CARE RECEIVE IT.
UNDIAGNOSED AND UNTREATED
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES HAVE A
SERIOUS IMPACT FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND THEIR LOVED ONES. FROM
NINETEEN NINETY ONE TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA SITE 58%
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SUICIDES. FOR THOSE AGE SIXTY
FIVE TO EIGHTY FOUR AND A 50%
INCREASE FOR THOSE EIGHTY FIVE
AND OLDER. AT SUICIDE RATES ARE
PARTICULARLY HIGH IN RULE PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IS SEVERELY
LACKING. IN CALIFORNIA THE
OLDER ADULT POPULATION WILL
INCREASE 64% BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. TO TWELVE MILLION
ADULTS AGE SIXTY AND ABOVE BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THE US CENSUS
BUREAU PROJECTS SENIOR CITIZENS
WHAT NUMBER YOUTH FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BONTA THE PHONE LINES I
HAVE TESTIFYING IS DR- JANET
FRANK A RESEARCHER ON AGING AND
ONE OF THE LEAD AUTHORS OF THE
STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE UCLA
CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY AND-
MISTER LEE KROHN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE. AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU- BEFORE WE- BRING IT
TO COMMITTEE- CAN HAVE THE
WITNESSES. MAKE A PRESENTATION.
JERRY HAD THE MIKE OFF BEFORE
WE START WITH ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS CAN WE HAVE THE
PRESENTATIONS. CALL. CAN THE
AT&T MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR OUR TWO PRESENTERS.
AND THIS IS RIGHT AT THE TNC
CENTERS ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU ARE ON A SECURE SPENT NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME AND WE CAN OPEN
YOUR MIND. I DID HAVE ONE
PERSON QUEUE UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. OF COURSE. SUPPOSED. TO
WE DO HAVE ONE QUUED UP ON THE
LINE EIGHT LINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THE RECORD. YEAH. WELCOME
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING I
THINK FUNDING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
AND I AM A COMMISSIONER AND
ALSO ON FACULTY AT THE UCLA
FIELDING SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. MY TESTIMONY TODAY
FOLKS LEVINE OUR RESEARCH THAT
SUPPORTS THE NEED FOR AN OLDER
ADULT ADMINISTRATIVE LEADER.
AND ALSO HELP US WITH JUST. IS
SUPPORTED AND BOTH SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN ON AGING.
OUR STUDY SPONSORED BY THE
NONPROFIT SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION- WAS
PROVIDED IN THE POLICY BRIEF-
THAT I SPENT LAST WEEK. THIS IS
THE FIRST STUDY THAT IS IN FACT
HOW WELL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SPONSORED BY THE MHSAA ARE
SERVING OLDER ADULTS DEFINED AS
PEOPLE SIXTY YEARS AND OLDER.
WE FOUND THE STICK OTHER. BUT
SMALL AND YES DISPARITY ACROSS
THE STATE. THANK YOU ARE OUT WE
CAN. TO THE OKAY THE NEEDS OF
ALL THE- I MEASUREMENTS AND
DATA WITH A NUMBER AND BOLD
COUNTY. AND OF A PORTANTINO'S
THAT THERE ARE WAS A LOT OF THE
THAT THE STATE. FOR OLDER
ADULTS NOT ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
OUR FOR SHOULD THE QUITE BY THE
TO SEVENTH DAYS BOOK ISSUED BY
COLLAR BECAME HEALTH PLANNING.
NOW I THOUGHT YOU SEE A LITTLE
BIT THREE. BUT AB EIGHTY THREE
EACH OTHER. MASTER ON A- DURING
THE PLANNING PROCESS OLDER
ADULTS. TO SUFFER WHAT ON THAT
NOT ONLY BE HERE HEALTH NEEDS
WHICH HURT AND- BY THE COLD BUT
MY- PANDEMIC. WITHIN THE
BROUGHT FOR A THE MASTER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR THE
TERMINAL. RECOMMENDING ARE
DENNIS DIRECT AND ARE ALSO. AND
RIGHT. PART SHOULD. VULNERABLE
AND RISK THE AND PEOPLE WITH
JUST A BILL. IN ORDER TO ASSURE
THAT MULLIN BECAME HEALTH THAT
OLDER ARE DRAFT. OUT THE MASTER
PLAN TO GET IMPLEMENTATION IT
WILL BE IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS
KEY POSITION IN PLACE. WITHOUT
STATE. AND LEADERSHIP OLDER
ADULTS ESPECIALLY OLDER ADULTS
WHO WERE LOW INCOME AND
MINORITY GROUPS WILL CONTINUE.
BEING UNDERSERVED. THEY ARE
UNDER TO THE TOWN OF ABOUT.
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND OLDER.
ARE IN NEED OF THE HERO AND
MENTAL SERVICES YEAH FY
EIGHTEEN ONLY 4% RECEIVED THOSE
NEEDED SERVICES. FOR OLDER
ADULTS ARE 16% OF THE ADULT
MEDICAID POPULATION AND LESS
THAN 2% RECEIVED EVEN ONE
SPECIAL CANNOT STOP ALL
SERVICES. EXEMPLIFIES DURING
THE PANDEMIC THE SITUATION IS
DIRE AND REQUIRES IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION. RIGHT NOW THERE IS
NO ONE AT THE STATE LEVEL WHO
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
THE SYSTEM BECOME MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I BELIEVE. IS WOULD
THERE BE A SECOND INDIVIDUAL AS
WELL. AT THIS POINT OPERATOR IF
IS THERE ANOTHER PERSON
AVAILABLE. AT&T OPERATOR IS
THERE ANOTHER CALLER. AND ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE
IN Q. HERE IT'S LINE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND SPEAK WHEN YOU'RE
READY. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
ZERO COACH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING. WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
SO. AB THREE EIGHTY THREE AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR-
FAVORABLE RESPONSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON I GUESS WE ARE
MOVING ON TO COMMENTS OF
SUPPORT BY THE WAY LET ME PASS
ON I WANT. LET ME PASS OUT ONE
MORE DO IN ORDER TO KEEP IT UP
BUT THERE ARE. I'M SORRY CAN
YOU REPEAT THAT. WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER THAT QUEUED UP DURING
THAT TIME I WOULD IT MIGHT BE
OUR WITNESS. THANK YOU OPERATOR
UP BEFORE THAT LET ME JUST
REPEAT THE NUMBER OR OFFER A
NEW NUMBER AS WELL FOR COLIN
PURPOSES. AT. 877-692-8957
AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
THE PIN NUMBER STAYS THE SAME-
PLEASE GO AHEAD OPERATOR. THAT
THE LINE IS LINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. SURELY
CROWN. PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MISCON. OKAY GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SHIRLEY CROWN AND I AM A SENIOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH A
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
MY PRESENTATION TODAY WILL
PROVIDE BACKGROUND ON MY
RESEARCH INTO MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES HERE IN CALIFORNIA BASED
ON FIFTEEN PLUS YEARS OF BEING
ON THE BOARD OF SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS FOCUSING ON THIS
ISSUE. THIS LED INTO CREATING
THE PROPOSAL AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
INCLUDES MOST OF THE FINDINGS
FROM THE UCLA STUDY PRESENTED
BY JANET FRANK. MY RESEARCH
INVOLVED MAKING CONTACT WITH
SEVERAL COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS WHAT I DISCOVERED
IS THAT UNDERSERVED OLDER
ADULTS WERE FACED WITH THE
ABSENCE OF COORDINATED SERVICES
WHICH MEANT THAT THERE WAS POOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INCONSISTENT
REPORTING CRITERIA HOWEVER.
SOME COUNTIES PREPARED PLANS
REQUESTING FUNDING BUT WHEN
FUNDS FOR SUPPLY THE
ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY USE THEM
FOR OTHER PROJECTS AND NOT
MENTAL HEALTH THIS TOLD ME
THERE WAS LITTLE OR NO
ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH IN MY
OPINION IS UNACCEPTABLE. IN
ADDITION TO THE ISSUES FACING
UNDERSERVED OLDER ADULTS I
BEGAN TO SERIOUSLY UNDERSTAND
THE EFFECTS OF MENTAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IMPACTING
THIS POPULATION. LONELINESS
ANXIETY DEPRESSION SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IN END OF LIFE ISSUES.
THESE ARE TAKING A TOLL ON THIS
POPULATION IN ADDITION
CHILDREARING IN PLACE SOCIAL
ISOLATION FEAR ANXIETY ALONG
WITH LIMITED ENGLISH CAPABILITY
AND A LACK OF KNOWLEDGE ME
TECHNOLOGY I DID BUT IDENTIFIES
MORE ISSUES FACING THIS
POPULATION ACCELERATED BECAUSE
OF THE CORVIDS PANDEMIC. AB
THREE EIGHTY THREE DOES TO
ADDRESS MANY OF IS. ANIKA SOME
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ASPECTS
FOR EXAMPLE I THINK THIS IS
CRITICAL STANDARDIZE GERIATRICS
TRAINING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS THAT WOULD COVER.
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC ETHICS-
JUROR OF THE G. G. DEMOCRATIC
DIVERSITY AMONG THIS POPULATION
NEEDLESS TO SAY CREATING THE
POSITION OF OLDER ADULT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADMINISTRATOR
HAS IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT FOR INITIATING THE
STATE LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. PLUS THIS
POSITION WOULD BE FINANCED WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUNDS
IMPORTANT FACT I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO PASS THIS BILL AS WE
HAVE A GROWING POPULATION
IMPACTED BY MENTAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS COUNT
OF THE OPERATOR ARE THERE. IS
THAT CAN DEADLINE BE OPEN NOW
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH ANY OTHER
SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE THAT'S QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT
WHEN I GET THERE LINE NUMBER.
AND WE'LL GO TO THE LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SECURED TO SECURE OUR
BORDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE. BARTON
HEARING TODAY TO PROVIDE OUR
SUPPORT TO SING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHIRLEY CHROME EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE WE SUPPORT THAT
BILL WHOLE HEARTEDLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN Q. GREAT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO. GREAT THANK YOU. AND I
SHOULD ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE. ANYONE WITH QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. IS THAT
GOOD OF A BILL MISTER SALAS.
PRECIADO THANK YOU I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE ON THE BILL THIS THE
BILL DOES ENJOY SUPPORT
SUPPORT- SO IF THERE ARE NO
MORE QUESTIONS. GIVE A CLOSING
COMMENT JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. BUT SEVERAL MOTION BY
BOERNER HORVATH SECOND BY
BLANCA RUBIO DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. NAZARIAN HI NAZARIAN
AYE THE PAL THE PAL HI FOR HER
THAT. ONE OF I CALLED. CALDERON
I LACK AYE LACKEY AYE RADIUS
BLOCK A RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
LUCK ON TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE
AT NECK THE MAY AB FORTY
MISSISSIPPI TRAINERS. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR IT AB FIVE
FORTY THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO PACE. THE
PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
PACE PROVIDES ALL INCLUSIVE
MEDICARE AND MEDICARE COVERED
BENEFITS FOR VULNERABLE SENIORS
THREE ONE STOP SHOP PAY
CENTERS. IS A PROVEN SUCCESS
RATE LOWERING HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND NURSING HOME ADMISSIONS
IMPROVING HEALTH AND QUALITY OF
LIFE AND ALSO SAVING MONEY IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT PAYSAFE
CALIFORNIA OVER SIXTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY BUT EVEN THOUGH PIECE IS
A MODEL OF CARE FOR SENIORS
MANY BENEFICIARIES ARE UNAWARE%
OF HOW PACE CAN BENEFIT THEM.
AND REFERRALS ARE CURRENTLY
VERY FRAGMENTED AS A RESULT
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
ELIGIBLE SENIORS ARE ENROLLED
IN PACE PROGRAMS ARE ONLY 11%
OF ELIGIBLE SENIORS ENROLLED SO
AT EIGHTY FIVE FORTY AIMS TO
IMPROVE BENEFIT YOUR AWARENESS
AND ACCESS TO PACE THE BILL
WILL REQUIRE PACE TO BE OFFERED
AS A MEDIC CAL PLAN CHOICE.
REQUIRE PACE TO BE IDENTIFIED
REQUIRE THE DH CS TO ESTABLISH
AN AUTO REFERRAL PROCESS TO
PREFER BENEFICIARIES TO PACE
REQUIRE ASSESSMENT INCLUDE
CRITERIA TO HELP IDENTIFY
WHETHER OF BENEFICIARIES
ELIGIBLE FOR PACE AND ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF ENROLLMENT BY
EXEMPTING MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES WERE ENROLLED IN
PACE FOR MEDICINE MANDATORY FOR
PASSIVE ENROLLMENT IN MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE. FIVE TWO ONE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND CHAIR
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THE
SPELLING FOR WORKING WITH WITH
ME AND MY TEAM ON WITH THAT I
AM PLEASED TO WELCOME TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE WE
HAVE A LINCOLNS WHO AT IS THE
CHIEF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND
COMPLIANCE WITH UNLOCK PACE. I
AND MARIE IS A MORE AT THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OFFICER
AT THE CENTER. FOR ALTERS
INDEPENDENCE. OPENS ONE OF THEM
ON THE ON THE IN THE- THEY YOU.
THANK YOU. AT EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE HAVE
THE WITNESSES. CERTAINLY YUP
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THE
FIRST THAT IS QUEUED UP AS LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF
OF ALZHEIMER'S ARE LAID OUT.
WHICH I COUNTY IS OF THE BELT
YOU. OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
HAVE EITHER MISS EILEEN KOONTZ
OR MARIA'S AMORA- THAT THE
WITNESSES FOR THE BILL PRESENT.
OKAY THEY DIALED IN WHERE WE
DON'T KNOW THEIR NAMES SO WE
HAVE TO HAVE THEM QUEUE UP IN
THE AND QUEUE IT UP WITH THE
OTHERS ARE QUEUING UP AT THE
SAME TIME. THE NEXT IS LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS CHARLES SCHOOL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING. ON THE
COMMISSION ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT
OF. ANY EXPANSION OF THE PEACE
PROGRAM AND WE FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER. LET'S
TRY AGAIN LINES SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY MONEY IS A LOT AT PRESIDENT
AND CEO FOR THE CENTER FOR
ELDERS AND DEPENDENT BUT THEY
CAN OAKLAND AND HAVE BEEN
SERVING EASTBAY SENIORS FOR
NEARLY FORTY YEARS. IT'S A
GREAT. AT AN ALTERNATIVE TO
NORTH HOMES TWO. FOR SENIOR
POPPY. NEEDS ARE. CURRENTLY
SERVE OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS THREE SIXTY FOUR
KEY CENTER AND ALTERNATIVE CARE
SITES. IN TWENTY TWO COUNTIES.
THE BULK OF THESE ARE MET
HEALTH AND- OR FOUR DOOR ALEX
FROM. AND DESPITE IS A NUMBER
OF BARRIERS MAKE IT FOR MARVIN
TO CONNECT IN A ROW IN. FOR
EXAMPLE MANY CALVIN WHO ARE
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE FOR PACE
AND LYFT IN ROLLING THE MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE NOT CONSISTENT
INFORMED THAT THEY MAY BE
ASSESSED FOR PEACE ELIGIBILITY.
INFORMATION ABOUT PACE
CONTAINED IN SOME THAT ACCOUNT
MANAGED CARE ENROLLMENT
MATERIALS IS INACCURATE AND OUT
OF DATE. PART OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES HEALTH
CARE OPTIONS WEBSITE CONTAINS
LIMITED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CASE. EIGHT FIVE FORTY INCREASE-
WHEN OF PAY AND FOR. ACCESS TO
PACE IN SEVERAL WAYS. INCLUDING
BY. THE AGE ACTED GREEN
BENEFITS. FOR POTENTIAL PAYS
ELIGIBILITY AND PROVIDE
OUTREACH TO THEM TO SEE IF THEY
WISH TO BE A FAST PACED
ELIGIBILITY. EIGHTEEN TO COUNTY
AFTER. THANK CAL OVER HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE IN TWENTY TWO
ONE BUT THE BENEFICIARY SERVES.
TWO ONE IT WOULD COST TO CARE
FOR THEM- OUTSIDE OF PACE.
THAT'S ADDITION TO THE LIVES OF
FRANCE. WE BELIEVE IN HAPPY
ACCESS TO PAY THE CHAIN THAT
FORTY. WE'RE TALKING SAVINGS
FOR THE STATE. THIRTY THREE I'M
HAPPY THAT THE THIS. AND ALL
WISH TO THANK AUTHOR FOR FACING
AN THANK YOU FOR TIME CONSIDER.
THANK YOU MISTER MOORE. IS MISS
CRUZ ON LINE BY NATURE. THE
ONCE AGAIN PRESS. ONE ONE NINE
ZERO. LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND SEVENTEEN POSSIBLY
YOUR MUTE BUTTONS ON. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THERE- COACH BUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FORTY.
THANK YOU OPERATOR IS ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE LINE FOR SUPPORT.
AT WE HAVE ONE MORE IMPERIAL
WILL TRY AGAIN IT'S LINE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE.
TWENTY THREE. WE HAD ANOTHER
QUEUE UP WE'LL TRY THAT IT'S
LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU OFFICE
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE ALL DAVID
FEINBERG REPRESENTING A R. P.
WE ARE NOT STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL I WISH TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR SEDUCTION. OPERATOR
ANY OTHER NDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT. ANY OTHER CALLERS
AGAIN WEREN'T. ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME INCREDIBLE CO
REPRESENTING MULTI HEALTH AND
ARE FOR PEACE PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA CALLING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FORTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE IN ONE THING. OKAY. ONE
MOMENT OF THE FOR TO USE OUR-
NOT NOT AT ALL I WAS JUST GONNA
SAY BELIEVE A MISS EILEEN
KOONTZ IS CALLING IN SHE WAS
HAVING A BIT OF A CHALLENGE- SO
LET'S JUST GIVE IT A- COUPLE OF
SECONDS HERE TO SEE IF SHE CAN
JOIN IN. OKAY. SEND ONE IN THE
ROOM. IN SUPPORT. NO OKAY. ANY
LUCK OPERATOR. WE DO HAVE-
THREE THAT HAVE QUEUED UP BY
MINE NUMBER I HAVE NOT HAD THE
A WITNESS STYLE AND ON A
SPEAKER LINE. OR WITH THIS
MONTH SHE WE TRIED THE YES. THE
PORK MINDS OKAY YES NEGATIVE
BLIND THIRTY LINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS VITAL
CHAN'S AND I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
TECHNOLOGICAL ERRORS. MY DAY
TODAY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THAT CAMPAIGN BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WEARING CHAIR- ARMONK
STARTED FIFTY YEARS AGO IN THE
CHINATOWN NORTH BEACH AREA OF
SAN FRANCISCO TO SERVE
UNDERSERVED AND VULNERABLE
SENIORS. AND FOUNDED THE PAID
MODEL OF CARE TO ENABLE NURSING
HOMES SENIOR. TO REMAIN IN
THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES WE
ARE PROUD THAT CASES THE
NATIONAL MODEL AVAILABLE IN
THIRTY ONE STATES AND PROVIDES
INDIVIDUALIZED CARE TO OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS. I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD FROM
THE ASSEMBLY NUMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND MARINES OF
MARA ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF THE
MODEL BUT I'D JUST LIKE TO ADD
THAT PAGE IS THAT PREVENTING
COST EFFECTIVE MODEL OF
INTEGRATED CARE THAT PROVIDES
ALL THE SERVICES THAT ARE
NEEDED BY FRAIL SENIORS CHEN
ABLE THEM TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITY. INCLUDING PRIMARY
CARE- MEDICAL CARE LONG TERM
SERVICE AND SUPPORTS CONCEPTUAL
SERVICES RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THE
PACE PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS TO PURCHASE INTENT
INCLUDING SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN HOSPITAL USE
IMPROVEMENTS AND HEALTH STATUS
AND DELAYS ON THE ON SET OF
EXTENDED NURSING. HOME CARE.
VERY HIGH RATES OF BENNETT
SHARING AND PARTICIPANTS
SATISFY AND WHAT WE ARE BURKE
YOUR PREFERRED. WELL CASES
OPTION FOR MEDICARE BENEFITS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON NINE
VERY. MATTER BENEFITS ARE
ELIGIBLE IMPAIR CAL WHERE IT
AVAILABLE AREN'T. MANY ARE NOT
A OF PAGE THEN MAILING AWARE
THAT CHOICE OF ENROLLING PAID
AS A RESULT- WE'RE LOOKING FOR
ON A- FIVE WITH A ACCESS. AND
AWARENESS TO PAY IS BY
REQUIRING PASTED. IN A MOMENT
MUCH AN OPERATIVE OPS FOR THESE
REASONS I'M HELPING TO HAPPY TO
BE. A FIVE FORTY AND WANT TO
THANK SOMEONE PETRIE-NORRIS
ENTRY IT MIGHT TO THANK THANK
YOU MEMBER AND FORWARD CRUSH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OUR IS THERE
ANY OPERATORS ANYONE ONLINE FOR
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AS A
REMINDER PRESS ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AND WE DO HAVE A
NUMBER IN Q. ALREADY THE FIRST
ONE IS TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HERE IN NO I'M NOT MINE
WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE OPERATOR. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO THE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I COULD MORNING
SATELLITE HERE ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
CHARLOTTE REYNOLDS WITH HOW THE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
INNOVATIVE INTEGRATED HEALTH
FRESNO PAGES BAKERSFIELD PAYS
AND- KEEP PACE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER. YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO JOHN PORTER CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE WHICH
SUPPORT AB FIVE FORTY THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AND ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOUR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE ONE IT COMES ON THE
LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS TRENT
SMITH CALLING ON BEHALF OF HOW
LONG TERM- PARTNERSHIP HEALTH
PLAN AND HEALTH PLAN OF SAN
MATTEO. WANT TO BE CLEAR OUR
CLIENTS DISAPPOINT DO NOT HAVE
A FORMAL OPPOSE POSITION- BUT
THEY DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL WE'VE BEEN HAVING SOME
MEETINGS WITH THE SPONSOR AND
WITH THE AUTHORED SHARE SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS. I KNOW WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE PEACE
PROGRAM IN FACT HELLO OPTIMA
OPERATES A PACE PROGRAM AND
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN
RECENTLY ISSUED TWO LETTERS OF
SUPPORT FOR PEACE PLAN BUT
NEVER SERVICE AREA. OUR CONCERN
WITH THE BILL IS WITH THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS- AT SOME OF
YOU MAY KNOW KALLONI ORGANIZED
HEALTH SYSTEMS ARE THE SOLE
PROVIDER OF MEDICAL SERVICES IN
THEIR SERVICE AREA. THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COORDINATION OF CARE WE HAVE
THIS BILL CONTEMPLATES HAVING
AN EVALUATION- IN AN OPTION
PRESENTED TO BE ENROLLED BEFORE
THEY ARE ENROLLED IN THE
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLAN- AND
WE SEE THAT OF THE DETRIMENT TO
THE MODEL THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE
FOR CLOSE TO THIRTY YEARS- WE
HAVE SUGGESTED TO THE SPONSOR
AND- AUTHOR OF THAT. INCLUDES
COUNTY- THAT WE LEAVE THE
ANNULMENT PROCESS THE EMPLOYEES
AND THAT WE WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT- ON THE EVALUATION-
AND- THEN WILL LEASE TO
DETERMINE IF THEY ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR PACE. AND THEN WORK ON SOME
SORT OF A WAY TO INFORM THEM OF
THEIR ELIGIBILITY MAKE THEM
AWARE- AND PRESENT THEM WITH
THAT OPTION BUT WE WOULD LIKE
THAT PROCESS DONE AFTER THE
ENROLLMENT. SO THAT WE MAINTAIN
THE CORE PRINCIPLE OF THE COAST
MODEL YOUR HOPEFUL OF COMING UP
WITH SOME COMPROMISED LANGUAGE
BEFORE THE BILL'S HEARD AND
HEALTH. COMMITTEE HI AND
WELCOME CAN YOU HAVE SOME HOPE
WE COULD COUGH. THE MIX DAYS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU UP MAYBE THE WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER AS I THINK IT WAS
MISS SMITH AS MISTER SMITH
NOTED WE HAVE BEEN IN HER- THAT.
AND ORGANIZATIONS HE READ. A
WILL CONTINUE TO ON A SOLUTION
FOR CLOSE COUNTIES WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO CREATE THAT IN
ASSEMBLY NEW ADMINISTRATIVE
HURDLE I WANT TO STREAMLINING.
ENROLLMENT AS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE AFRICA'S COUNTIES AS WELL
IT'S NOT BECAUSE COUNTY SPONSOR
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THAT
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THAT AS WELL
AND KEEP THIS COMMITTEE UPDATED
AS IT MOVES. THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE OPERATOR ARE IN
LINE FOR OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. GREAT LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE. YES
MYSTERIES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS I
THINK THAT WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT IS THE WORD OPTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SENIORS HAVE
OPTIONS WE DO KNOW THAT STAYING
IN YOUR HOME STAY IN YOUR
COMMUNITY IT'S PROBABLY THE
BEST THING THAT OUR SENIORS CAN
DO IN EVERY SEPTEMBER WE HAVE A
SENIOR ADVOCACY WEEK AND I ASK
OUR SENIORS WHAT IS IT THAT
MOST CONCERNS YOU AND THAT IS
ALMOST ALWAYS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE- BEING ABLE TO STAY IN
THEIR OWN HOME STAY IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITY. SO GIVING THEM
THAT OPTION AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT THEY CAN KNOW
WHAT THEY CAN DO WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM I THINK IT'S
A GREAT THING SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS I DID HEAR
THE OPPOSITION. EIGHT I WANTED
TO UNDERSTAND IT. BUT I'M SURE
YOU UNDERSTOOD THE OPPOSITION
BETTER AND WILL BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THEM BUT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON. ON THIS ISSUE AND
WITH THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE. A CHORUS OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL I THINK
PEACE IS ONLY GONNA BE
EXPANDING AS D. GENERATION OF
ELDERLY ALSO EXPANDS OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT. DECADE OR
TWO DECADES AND SO THIS IS
GONNA BE THE PROGRAM THAT'S
GOING TO PROVIDE A GREAT TOOL
FOR THE STATE FOR BOTH COST
SAVINGS AS WELL AS MEETING THE
NEEDS- AT EVERY APPROPRIATE
PLACE- SO WITH THAT- THIS BILL
DOES DO SUPPORT ENJOY SUPPORT
SUPPORT. LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS FOR A FOR A SECOND BY
LACKEY TO PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
NAZARIAN HI NAZARIAN IS THE
PAL. THE PAL I FOR OVER A- PART
OF HER BACK I CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE RADIUS. RADIUS FIVE LAKH
RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO BY. THEY
GIVE A SPEECH IN NOISE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. NEXT UP IS A.
B. SIX THIRTY SIX. SOME A
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. WELCOME
MISTER CAP. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RECENTLY
THERE'S BEEN A RISE IN ABUSE
CASES INVOLVING INDEPENDENT
LIVING FACILITIES PROVIDING
SUBSTANDARD CARE FOR THE
RESIDENTS AND SOME OF THESE
FACILITIES THE CARE SO XTREME
THAT CAN BE CONSIDERED ELDER
ABUSE BECAUSE INDEPENDENT
LIVING FACILITIES ARE LICENSED
IT'S OFTEN THE LOCAL CODE
COMPLIANCE ENTITIES TO
UNDERTAKE ENFORCEMENT AND CLOSE
SUBSTANDARD FACILITIES THROUGH
CODE COMPLIANCE CASES CURRENT
LAW DESIGNATES SPECIFIC
ENTITIES THAT ARE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE INVESTIGATIVE
INFORMATION FROM ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. AB SIX
THREE SIX WILL PERMIT ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND THEIR
ATTORNEYS TO ADDRESS
SUBSTANDARD CARE IN INDEPENDENT
LIVING FACILITIES APPARENT
TELEPHONICALLY WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE KIMBERLY PIERCE WHO IS THE
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
MANAGER WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. TOOK ABOUT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE FIND
THE- MISTER KIMBERLY PIERCE
ONLINE. WE DO HAVE ONE THAT IS
CUED UP- WE'LL SEE IF IT IS HER
LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE
SEVENTEEN. YOU HAVE A FAMILY
THAT ARE YOU. DO YOU MORE THAN
A FEW TO UP NOW WILL TRY AGAIN
LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MATALIN COOPER FROM
NIELSEN LOOKS MORE ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KIMBERLY PIERCE I'M GOOD
MORNING CHAIR NAZARIAN AND VICE
CHAIR VOEPEL AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
CHAIRS ON THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES MANAGER FOR THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO'S HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AGING AND
INDEPENDENCE SERVICES. IT'S A
TODAY IN THE COUNTY IS PROUD TO
BE THE SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION. I BELIEVE BILL
THIRTY SIX WOULD ALLOW ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AND THEIR
ATTORNEYS FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE
OF INVESTIGATING SOME STANDARD
INDEPENDENT LIVING FACILITIES.
HOUSING OLDER AND DEPENDENT
ADULT. IT'S NO SECRET TO THIS
COMMITTEE THAT ARE POP OUR
POPULATION IS AGING ACCORDING
TO CALIFORNIA'S NEW MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING THE STATE OVER SIXTY
POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO
DIVERSIFY AND GROW FASTER THAN
ANY OTHER AGE GROUP. BY TWENTY
THIRTY TEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE AN OLDER
ADULT MAKING UP ONE QUARTER OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION. WITH
THIS INCREASE COMES SEVERAL
CHALLENGES ONE OF WHICH IS AN
INCREASED PREVALENCE OF- ELDER
ABUSE INCLUDING FINANCIAL
EXPLOITATION EMOTIONAL ABUSE
PHYSICAL ABUSE SEXUAL ABUSE AND
NEGLECT. FURTHERMORE THERE'S
BEEN A PARALLEL RISE IN ABUSE
CASES INVOLVING SUB STANDARD
INDEPENDENT LIVING FACILITIES
THEY'RE KNOWN AS IOWA. I'LL
LOVE BURKE I'M LICENSED
FACILITIES THAT PROVIDE CARE TO
MULTIPLE IN THE INDIVIDUAL IN
ONE RESIDENT. AT THE COST OF IN
LICENSE FACILITIES RISES THE
DEMAND FOR THAT LEVEL OF CARE
MORE AND MORE VULNERABLE LOW
INCOME ADULTS ARE RELYING ON
I'LL LEFT FOR THEIR CARE NEEDS.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THESE
FACILITIES PROVIDE EXTREMELY
SUBSTANDARD CARE WHICH CAN BE-
CAN MEET THE LEGAL DEFINITION
OF THE OLDER GEAR. FOR LICENSED
FACILITIES APS CAN EASILY SHARE
INFORMATION WITH A LICENSING
AGENCIES SUCH AS COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING. HOWEVER FOR IOS
CLOSURES OFTEN ACCOMPLISHED
THROUGH LOCAL CODE ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. DOWN THERE ATTORNEY.
INSIGNIA IN RECENT WORKING HAS
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY TO ROOT
OUT THE SILENCE THAT ARE BAD
ACTORS BROUGH CODE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. DUE TO CURRENT LAW
APS CANNOT ASSIST THOSE EFFORTS
WITHOUT A COURT ORDER INCLUDING
EVEN CONFIRMING FOR THEM WHICH
ADDRESSES WE HAVE VISITED
FREQUENTLY TO INVESTIGATE ABUSE.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR ATS TO
SEE I- LEFT WITH SHEETS HANGING
FROM THE CEILING IN ROOMS
CREATING MAKESHIFT WALLS
BETWEEN MULTIPLE BUNK BEDS.
GETTING AS MANY RESIDENTS INTO
ONE ROOM AS POSSIBLE OR TO SEE
FAULTY WIRING IN ONE CASE A PS
WITH INVESTIGATING THEIR OF A
HOT ELECTRICAL WIRE RUNNING
THROUGH THE SHOWER CREATING
SHOCK TO ANYONE WHO TOOK A
SHOWER. WE'VE SEEN UNSAFE GATES
LOCKED FROM THE OUTSIDE
PREVENTING CLIENTS FROM BEING
ABLE TO BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
FIRE AND EMERGENCY AND
PREVENTING FIRST RESPONDERS
FROM BEING ABLE TO GAIN ACCESS
QUICKLY. CURRENT WHAT
DESIGNATES THIS. ENTITIES THAT
ARE ENTITLED TO RECEIVE
INVESTIGATIVE INFORMATION FROM
EIGHT PM. WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE ONE FIVE SIX
ONE ZERO POINT FOUR FIVE LIMITS
THE TERM TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WHICH MEANS
ONLY LOCAL POLICE SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES AND PROBATION OFFICERS.
ATS OF THE BILITY TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
SEVERELY LIMITED BY THIS
DEFINITION BECAUSE CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DO NOT
MEET THE DEFINITION OF A LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO THE
STATE LAW INCLUDED IN THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW APS TO SHARE
INVESTIGATORY INFORMATION WITH
CODE ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
THEIR ATTORNEYS TO ALLOW CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND THOROUGHLY
INVESTIGATE AND TO SHUT DOWN.
SUB STANDARD IOWA. LASTLY THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW APS TO SURE
NOT. INFORMATIONAL A FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
SPECIFICALLY CHARGED WITH THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE ELDER OR
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE AND
CROSSERS FICTIONAL CASES.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES COORDINATE
ON CASES THAT CROSS STATE LINES
DOWN THAT PREY ON SENIOR
CITIZENS. WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO STATE WHY
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL THE
COORDINATION CALIFORNIA WILL BE
MORE FOCUSED EFFICIENT AND
TIMELY. INFORMATION WILL ONLY
BE SHARED WITH FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CHARGED
WITH THE INVESTIGATION- ELDER
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE AND FOR
THE FULL PURPOSE OF
INVESTIGATING A PROPERTY WHERE
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF AN-
ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT RATHER
THAT IS AT RISK. FOR EXAMPLE
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT- PREY ON OLDER ADULTS AND
OUR- TYPICALLY FINANCIAL WE
HAVE- OLDER ADULTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHO SPENT THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS TO CRIMINAL. AND
CURRENTLY WE CANNOT PROVIDE THE
FEDERAL AGENCIES INVESTIGATING
THESE CRIMES WITH THE
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
RESIDENTS. OF FALLEN VICTIM. IN
APS WE SEE ROMANCE SCAMS WHICH
ARE US SCAMS WHERE A CLIENT
BELIEVES THERE ARE IN A
COMMITTED RELATIONSHIP WITH
SOMEONE WHO THEY REALLY ONLY
MET ON THE INTERNET. THEIR
GROUP OVER A PERIOD OF TIME AND
EVENTUALLY ASKED FOR MONEY TO
HELP WITH SOME BALLPARK CHIP
THAT. THE SCAMMER HAS TOLD THEM
ABOUT. WE'VE SEEN QUITE WHOSE
ON INTO OF DOLLARS DEPLETING
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THEY'RE HELPING THEIR
FIANCEE THE BOYFRIEND OR
GIRLFRIEND. I INTO TAKING OUT
LOANS SECOND MORTGAGES AT TIMES
WE'VE SEEN THEM WITH THEIR OWN
HOMES. THE LANGUAGE IN THIS
BILL IS VERY CLEAR AND VERY
SPECIFIC FOR REASON INFORMATION
CANNOT AND WILL NOT BE SHARED
OR USED FOR FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THIRTY SIX WILL ALLOW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DOWN THE
RETURNEES ON FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
THE INVESTIGATION OF ELDER
ABUSE TO INVESTIGATE AND SHUT
DOWN SUB STANDARD INDEPENDENT
LIVING FACILITIES THAT PREY
UPON. OLDER INDEPENDENT ADULTS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY SIX
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CITIZENS AND ENSURES OLDER
ADULTS HAVE THE CARE THEY NEED
AND DESERVE. I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL. SIX
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
HERE'S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MISS PEERS- IS
THERE ANYBODY NOW IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE OPERATOR. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AND WE DO
HAVE QUITE A FEW VERSES TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU HI THIS IS
CAROL SCHOOLS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
I'M WARING STRONG SUPPORTER
THIS BILL WE REALLY APPRECIATE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM OF BEING
UNREGULATED INDEPENDENT LIVING
FACILITIES. THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE- LEVIN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHE KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. NEXT GO TO LINE THIRTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MR THERE SHE
HAD TO RE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SIX. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRTH PAT MORAN WITH THE KERN
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
Q. THANK YOU OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. AND AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. FIRST WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SEVENTEEN PASSIVE YOU HAVE YOUR
MUTE BUTTON ON. MOVING ON NEXT
WE HAVE LINES OF THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JOHN
POINTER TO CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE. WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR I SHOULD'VE ALSO BEEN
SPECIFIC AND ASK IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN. ANY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. GREAT I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE EITHER SO WITH THAT.
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS NOTE THAT
JUST WON A RESPECTED REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU MR MENTION ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. GREAT AT
THIS BILL ALSO DOES ENJOY
SUPPORT SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. THESE
CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY SIX DO PASSED MOTION BY
BORROWER VAST SECOND BY
CALDERON THE SYRIAN HI NAZARIAN
AYE THE PAL THE PAL I'D WANT TO
WORK THAT WAY BOERNER HORVATH I
CALDERON CALDERON AYE LACKEY
AYE LACKEY AYE. BLANCA RUBIO
LOCKERBIE I STILL HAVE SIX
VOTES THAT'S. GREAT THANK
MISTER MEMBERS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THE LAST BILL FOR THE DAY.
IS GONNA BE A BILL. MY BILL
THAT I WILL BE PRESENTING FROM
RIGHT HERE. AND I'M GONNA TRY
TO KEEP IT AS BRIEF. WELL GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS THIS IS ONE OF
TO PASTE BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AND THE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT- LET ME
PASS ON THE GAVEL TO MR VOEPEL.
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE PRESENT. S.
IS OUT SINCE IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MOVED I WILL KEEP IT VERY BRIEF
AS WE KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN
FLEXIBILITY SAID OF BILL OUT
FOR PEACE ORGANIZATIONS TO
RESPOND TO COVER NINETEEN
CRISIS- DURING THIS TIME AND
WITH THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOW
FOR THOSE. CHANGES TO BE MADE
PERMANENT AND TO BE CODIFIED SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
OPERATOR IS ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES. AND ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
IF YOU ARE A WITNESS. ONE ZERO.
AND ONE MOMENT HERE WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE QUEUED UP. THE FIRST IS
LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THEN TWENTY ONE YEAR OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLEARLY. WE
CAN HEAR YES I'LL WELL WHAT IF
I APOLOGIZE I DID NOT CONTINUE
THIS IS MY OLD NUMBERS TO TRY
AND HELP MONICA MILLER ON
BEHALF OF. ON THE ON. THE EL AL
COMMITTEE THE END OF AT THE IF
YOU ABOUT TWENTY PEOPLE BALLOT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND ANY
OTHER WITH THE LEVEL WE DO HAVE
A ONE WE DO HAVE A WITNESS
HERE- IN QUEUES SINCE THE BRAND
IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THE MORNING
WHAT'S YOUR CHAIRMAN A MEMBER
IDENTIFICATION OUT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES JEWISH HOME. BERMAN
TICKETS. FIFTEEN YOUR CARE BUT-
SO FAR SERVICES IN THE CAMPAIGN
AND VALLEY FOR OVER EIGHTY. THE
LOS ANGELES HOW FOR OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINE YEARS. IN A
VERY SHORT BEEN IT COULD THE-
COLLECT. THAT ARE OUTLINED IN
AB FIVE TWENTY THREE. LAST YEAR
AS PART OF THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
ANY RESPECTABILITY UPON ABLE
PAPER. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
SAFELY AND MORE EFFECTIVELY
REACH ANSWER THE BILL ELDERLY
ALL OF THE BENEFITS FROM PEGS.
ALLOWING CONTINUED FLEXIBILITY
IN THE USE OF TELEHEALTH WILL
ENABLE INDIVIDUALS TO REACH
AMERICA PRESENTS DIFFICULTY
ARRANGING FOR INCREASED FROM
THAT THAT'S WHEN OUR FAMILY
THAT DID NOT WANT TO LEAVE
THEIR HOMES WE'VE HAD
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS WITH
PROVIDING TABLET DEVICES NOT
REQUIRING INTERNET ACCESS. OR
UTILIZING ZOOM. PROVISIONAL
ASSESSMENT. BUT THE FAMILY UP
FOR ME UP. TO IT THAT. AND
PLANNING MEETING. I ALSO WANT
TO SHOW THAT WE UTILIZED
PROMOTE MONITOR DEVICE. FIVE
SIGN AND- DATA CAN SHALL WE
HAVE GROUP HIM DEPARTMENT
VISITS. PROVIDED MORE
ASSESSMENT AND SHE WENT. SOME
OF. ALLOWING THAT THE TO THE
WORLD USING VERY AGREE
WORKSTREAM AND WELL PRIOR AND
IT HOME EASY FOR SOME. MANY
PARKING ARE WITHOUT INTERNET
ACCESS AND ALMOST ALL WITHOUT
FAX CAPABILITY. LET ME
ILLUSTRATE HIS REGARDING A
RECENT ENROLLEE LAST MONTH WITH
BLATANT CURRICULA. WE WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO LOWER PROVIDE
CARE NEEDED IF WE COULD NOT
UTILIZE THE VERBAL AGREEMENT.
ALLOWING PAY CENTER NEXT TO
PROVIDE NURSING SERVICE
PARTICIPANTS HOMES. THAT THEY
OTHERWISE ARE AUTHORIZED TO DO
UNDER THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
WELL WITHOUT YOU CAN MORE
EFFECTIVELY USE OF RESOURCES
AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO SERVICES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO HAVE
DIFFICULTY COMING TO THE PAID
CENTER. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
REDUCE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
VISITS PERFECT ACUTE
HOSPITALIZATION ADMISSIONS WITH
FREQUENT NURSING BUSINESS LET
ME SHARE MY STORY ABOUT ONE
PARTICIPANT WAS KNOWN IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT OF THE
FREQUENT FLYER. YOU HAVE
DIABETES AND HYPERTENSION
OPPOSITION TO DOCTOR PAYS FOR
HIM. APART OF THAT AND NEED TO
HOME. THE NURSES NO REPORT. HE
WAS ONLY CAMP FOOD BE. ONCE WE
KNOW THAT SLEEP ON BRIDGE. AND
THE GUY TEACHER TO GUIDE HAVE
DIED. PROVIDING FLEXIBLE TO ITS
TO CONTACT. GOING TO HOP OR IF
YOU HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH
COMPARE CONSENT WHAT ABLE
BETTER COORDINATION AT DISTRICT
PLANNING. ON MEETING WITH THE
CLIENTS THAT NEEDED ITEMS AND
MEDICATIONS AND INITIATE HOME
PLACEMENT AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY AT SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS TO THE STATE. FOR THESE
REASONS WERE HAPPY TO BE
SPONSORING AB FIVE TWENTY THREE
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
FOR INTRODUCING. THIS BILL
THANK YOU. AN OPERATOR DO WE
ALSO PETER. AS A WITNESS. WE DO
AND MR HANDLEY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTRANSLATED THANK YOU- THANK
YOU HIGH- IN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- I'M PETER
INFO I'M THE- RTO CALIPHATE BUT
THE PETITION FOR THE
ORGANIZATION FOR CALIFORNIA
AMBER VERY. PROUD TO BE
SPONSORING AB FIVE TWENTY THREE
I'LL BE BRIEF BECAUSE SO MUCH
HAS BEEN SAID ABOUT THIS BILL
BUT- HELPED UP DURING THE COPA
PANDEMIC- OFFER- THAT RETAINER
IS A SAFE ALTERNATIVE TO
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT. THE
NUMBER OF POSITIVE CASES AMONG
PAID PARTICIPANTS TO OUR%
SIGNATURE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
COMBATIVE NURSING HOMES- AT THE
WAY TO KEEP TRAIL SENIOR SAFE A
NAVAL THEM TYPICALLY REMAIN. IN
THE COMMUNITY. OUR MEDICAL CARE
SERVICE GRANTED SEVERAL.
COLLECTED TO. AS OF ITS TO
ABOUT TEN WHICH ITS- THE
POSSIBILITY THAT WELL THEY'RE
ALLOWING PEACE. TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND SAFELY SIR
PARTICIPANTS AND CAN MORE
EFFECTIVELY REACH ON A ROLL.
YOU PER ADU PURCHASED OF NEW
PARTICIPANTS SO WERE UP TWENTY
THREE GUNS WERE VERY HAPPY TO
BE SPONSORING AND SUPPORTING
THAT ALL WE WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR INTRODUCING IT AND
I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THERE ARE NONE.
AFTER AND THEY'RE GOING OCTOROK.
OPERATOR OVER THERE ANY. OTHER
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
PONTIFICATE AMONG EIGHT ONCE
AGAIN YOU DO WANT TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. HE HARPER WILL DOUBLE
HELLO AND FORTY GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
CARROLL SCHOOL TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
CONTINUING NEEDS REGULAR BATES
REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY FOR
INCREASING PACE EFFICIENCY AND
ACCESS THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE ELEVEN. KELLY
BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE
FOR OTHERS INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATION SERVING ALAMEDA
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES HERE
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE LINE OF. EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX
IT IS CONNECTED TO THE NEXT
LEVEL OF LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THERE WILL BE THE ONE.
STATION JERRY YEAH NINE FORTY
TWO PLEASE MUTE YOUR COMPUTER
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO.
EIGHTEEN WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JOHN
PORTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE WE SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. AND
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I DID HAVE ONE QUEUE
UP YOUR MIND SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVENTEEN.
HEARING NO RESPONSE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. I SEE
NONE AND ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NO QUESTIONS IN WHICH
CASE ON BEHALF OF THE PRESENTER
WE WOULD ASK FOR. A RESPECTFUL
AYE VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB FIVE TWENTY THREE DO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH NAZARIAN. VOEPEL HI
THE PELL I BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HI CALDERON
CALDERON I LACKEY AYE NIKE AYE
RAYOS FIVE YES I'D LIKE RUBIO
FIVE TO REVEAL I. BILL HAS SIX
VOTES THANK YOU THEIR HAS NOT
VOTED THE BILL IS OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS THAT NEED TO DO AN ADD
ON ON ANY OF THE BILLS THAT ARE
OUT TODAY. SHE. WITH YOU I HAVE
ADDED ON THANK YOU OKAY WITH
THAT SAID WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.